e aí galera que assistiu canal tudo bem
com vocês como é que esse final de ano
em que já comprou a sida empatava em 1
em que todo ano eu vou escrever vou ter
que pesquisar no google é reveillon que
escreve aqui tá aí gente esses dias a
justiça determinou o bloqueio do a
desaparecer líquido seminal essa meu
deixado o estado um louco que quer coisa
que te bloquetes ap como fazer isso não
é ilegal mas chegando aqui sei lá para
cá o ps não meia noite pode aprontar
mais prestam e se não beleza 48 horas
rápido e impossível a primeira hora se
uma faca também me ver ouvir ver e 13 já
estava assim ó ó o filme canção todas
sem saber o que era quatro horas em uma
sala estava ligando o juiz outro irmão
já estava casado joguei até atrapalhando
a investigação tanto apoio da instigação
bota o celular no modo avião graças a
deus eu toco e o que é que o meu a sap a
ver com isso que eu estou conversando
contigo desgraça eu não tenho nem tem um
número eu quero que tu briga com sua
esposa ela disse nós após conversa eu
quero ver isso em volta do negócio pra
você deu sete horas em um ataque de luta
eu estava me sentindo império vontade de
acender a fogueira 18 horas em matar
porque eu me descobri que meu celular
fazia ligação só quem tinha grande
torque como é que eu ia bater papo com
meus amigos
a oi vai a quito chega em casa viu mesmo
tirar foto rodava ó a galinha bota aí a
botafogo quem é cala e encheu
prorrogável valeu a contar com réver
passou mais um tempinho eu a tabela
estava me sentindo no século 15
gekko hora sofrida que eu passei pensa
em dora pensa que eu não via com esse
aparelhinho aqui no tcheco é o quinto
ponto ponto ponto com esse joelho fazer
uma coisa dizer séria sério prejuízo
rogers faça mais isso não há ainda a
doença e há doentes acabam aqui ó graças
a deus voltei já posso me comunicar
normalmente com as pessoas agora posso
travar com o do jeito tradicional onde
termina o vídeo aqui o primeiro link na
descrição desse vídeo é o safado mêtro
aplicativo que diz quanto por cento você
ande pontos possíveis e vagabunda lá
muito obrigada a assistir se viu até
aqui é nóis klien gostei aqui no youtube
volta lá no facebook ou do vídeo novo
você quer que ela clique em curtir marca
seus amigos que também sofre com os
negócios à parte escreve o canal nunca
perdeu um vídeo novo é muitas novidades
por aí nesse próximo lâmpa liu em noite
b e pj é bom que a gente é essa a
mensagem na hora que a namorada mandou
aqui eu tô indo fazer as unhas não
senhora
ei lugar